-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The House voted last week
to pass legislation
protecting same-sex marriages,
because everyone deserves
the right to be
secretly unhappy.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
the Biden administration
isn't worried
about Elon Musk's
ownership of Twitter
and doesn't view the platform
as being a vital part
of its political strategy.
Said Biden, "The future of
campaigning is buttons."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
37% of Republicans say
they don't want
former President Trump
to run in 2024,
so Trump's gonna take that hint
and just continue to run
for 2020.
[ Laughter ]
Before announcing
his Senate run,
Republican consultants
reportedly hired a law firm
to compile a 500-page dossier
on Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker.
It was just
the names of his kids.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, sure, now that he lost,
we're all sensitive.
[ Laughter ]
During a speech on Saturday
at the New York Young Republican
Club's annual gala,
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
complained
about liberal policies
and said, "You can pick up
a butt plug or a dildo
at Target nowadays."
Or more likely,
you go in to buy a dildo
and end up leaving with a
bunch of stuff you didn't need.
[ Laughter ]
That's how they get ya.
"Wait in the car, kids.
I'll be right back."
[ Laughter ]
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced last week
that she's leaving
the Democratic Party
and registering
as an independent
because if there's one thing
she's desperate,
it's for people to think
she's "indie."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced that she's leaving
the Democratic Party.
No word on what kind of party
she's going to.
I'm gonna say a Muppet rave?
[ Laughter ]
The federal government
is set to run out of money
on Friday at midnight.
But it was worth it
for those Taylor Swift tickets.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
Archaeologists in Florida
believe they've discovered
a shipwreck from the 1800s
in the sand of Daytona Beach.
It's surprising because
normally all you find there
are train wrecks.
[ Laughter ]
"Take this picture.
I promise they'll never use it
in a late-night talk show."
[ Laughter ]
Comedian Dave Chappelle
brought Elon Musk up onstage
during a show last night
in San Francisco.
You mean, San Francisco,
where a bunch of tech people
live?
How did that go?
-Don't say nothing.
-It's like bringing Mel Gibson
onstage at the Apollo.
They don't like you there.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Bloomberg News
published an op-ed last week
titled "We Have to Talk
About Adolf Hitler,"
which was also
the least-popular song
on the "Encanto" soundtrack.
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue,
everybody.